[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
we are one of the least violent podcasts
on the internet more than 93 percent
non-violent so
so far we make no promises violence
could happen
um especially if we were to hold
a moment of silence that would by
definition according to some people
be uh violent i think
actually we have to reconfigure our
statistics i think we must be 100
violent on account of silence being
violence and also words being violence
therefore be we speaking or be we silent
we are engaging in violence
you say biwi that's weird i would also
just point out that at a sonic level
we have this very thing playing out at a
scale that we don't really intuit it but
basically
uh sound is waves and so you have the
peaks and the troughs right
physics is violence physics is violence
that's where you're going
well my my point was that wherever you
define
the noise and the silence and the
interspersing of them in order to make
the frequencies
you would find um but maybe the liminal
spaces aren't violence maybe the
transitions between them are not in fact
violence maybe that's
that's the crux um if the transitions
are not violent that is because somebody
has
overlooked them and soon enough they
will be redefined
into violence yes um except if they are
wielded by certain people and then they
will be declared non-violent by
definition for sure this is episode 43
it is episode 43 which is wild
a bit yep all right so where should we
start where would you like to start ah
um i was not expecting that question
somehow i guess turnabout is fair play
um well i thought that i thought that
you had some places you wanted to start
but
uh why don't we if you don't
uh start with
this memorandum that came out yesterday
uh from the executive office of the
president
september 4th 2020 memorandum for the
heads of executive departments and
agencies
from i did not look up how to pronounce
this guy's name russell vaught
vout something subject training in the
federal government
i'm just gonna read uh it's not very
long but i'll read you
i'll read the first three paragraphs
here for those not watching
it has come to the president's attention
that executive branch agencies have
spent millions of taxpayer dollars to
date training government workers to
believe divisive
anti-american propaganda for example
according to press reports employees
across the executive branch have been
required to attend trainings
where they are told that quote virtually
all white people contribute to racism
or where they are required to say that
they quote benefit from racism
according to press reports in some cases
these trainings have further claimed
that there is racism embedded in the
belief that america is the land of
opportunity
or the belief the most qualified person
should receive a job
these types of trainings not only run
counter to the fundamental beliefs which
our nation has stood since its inception
but they also engendered division and
resentment within the federal workforce
we can be proud that as an employer the
federal government has employees of all
races ethnicities and religions
we can be proud that americans from all
over the country seek to join our
workforce and dedicate themselves to
public service
we can be proud of our continued efforts
to welcome all individuals
who seek to serve their fellow americans
as federal employees however
we cannot accept our employees receiving
training that seeks to undercut our core
values as americans and drive division
within our workforce
this is terrible really this is
appalling i mean
i don't usually use the term evil but i
think in this case i'm going to invoke
it
um this is going to be good well
actually i'm just giving voice
to the blue perspective on this move
it is by blue here you don't mean the
police you mean the democrats
the democrats by the definition this is
still members
this this move is evil because it
emanates from the trump administration
right um anything anything that emerges
from the trump
administration especially when it is so
clearly actually from the president
himself
must be evil you don't have to know what
he said
you know that if he said it it's evil
right now the awkward thing
is let's just say joe biden
were to win this election and
the very same decree were to be issued
by a biden administration
i would be forced as much as i am not a
fan of joe biden i would be forced to
admit that this is an
important moment that this is progress
and that this needed to be done
as unpopular as it may be as indeed you
are forced
without any you know affection for trump
or his
policies or his abilities as a leader
in most regards to say this is important
and powerful and much needed and uh
hopefully it begins to affect some of
the changes that actually need to happen
are you suggesting i need to walk back
my claim that this is evil
i am okay all right maybe i should walk
back my claim that this is evil and say
it is um
you know evil minus some amount based on
the fact that it is the right thing to
do
even though it is being generated by the
trump administration i'm not sure this
isn't just confusing at this point
all right you think i'm confusing people
yes my point is actually
that uh this did need to be done and um
it would be welcome news to anybody who
is interested in seeing
uh what is important about america
preserved
it should be welcome news but many of
the people who should be on that side
will no doubt either have to ignore it
on the basis that it needed to be done
and they don't want to allow anything
that brings credit to the president
to be discussed or they will decry it
for some reason
because it is necessary to do so because
of the principle that we've mentioned
here before which is
anything trump does is by definition
wrong that's right
so um you don't need to show my screen
again zach but the very the final
sentence of this
short memorandum which again came out
yesterday on september 4th
reads the divisive false and demeaning
propaganda of the critical race theory
movement
is contrary to all we stand for as
americans and should have no place in
the federal government
there are a few sentences i can imagine
that i would agree with more this is
this is exactly right
and um one of the connections that we've
been making over the last
boy you know dozens actually of episodes
at this point
is that there is a clear
connection between the critical race
theory that has taken over
uh institutions of higher ed
for a few decades now and is now crept
out and now stormed out
into places like the media and courts
and
now the streets that the rhetoric that
we hear
from the people who actually engage in
rhetoric rather than just engaging in
violence who are on the streets now
is are engaging in exactly the same
words the same thought patterns
and they are intellectual inheritors
whether or not they recognize it
of critical race theory so this is this
is the same thing it manifests
differently
in a college classroom and in a
you know the editorial board of nature
magazine
and in the editorial board of new york
times
and in decisions by rioters to
you know hurl human feces or set fire to
things on the streets of portland and
many other cities
but it's it all is traceable back to the
same and again to use this language from
this memorandum
divisive false and demeaning propaganda
yep it uh you know
critical race theory has now broken into
the mainstream consciousness it was
certainly
trending on twitter uh today
i think it may even still be trending uh
so the fact is well that's
i mean that's presumably because of this
it is because of this but i think the
point
is to the extent that it was true months
ago to say
that critical race theory had some
important relationship to what we were
seeing but that most of the people who
were engaged wouldn't know that that
they wouldn't understand that that's
what they were
deriving this from this is now changing
we are actually
um through one mechanism or another
converging on a moment at which you can
invoke critical race theory and we may
have different
opinions on whether that's a positive or
negative thing
but at least it is recognized to have
this relationship
right and you know the workforce
trainings uh that are being referred to
here and that we've talked about on
several other episodes
uh often come with a couple of books
that increasingly people are recognizing
uh which we've also talked about white
fragility by robin d'angelo how to be an
anti-racist by ibram x kendi
uh so those um those
books themselves which many people
watching and listening will have been
forced to read by trainings you know
either in the federal government or not
these trainings are hardly limited to
the federal government but there's no
there's no way for this kind of
memorandum to reach beyond the federal
government at least to begin with
um those those books are
a a even more direct you know a shorter
line of connection
uh from critical race theory they are
the manifestations in sort of the
popular
popular press as opposed to the
so-called scholarly
uh academic papers and i just have to
laugh and i
say scholarly because there's there's
it's anti-intellectual at best
it is yes well let's put it this way
scholarly could mean
two things and this is gonna become a
theme uh during
today's discussion for various reasons
but scholarly
could mean that it aspires to
insight of the kind that a scholar might
aspire to or it could mean that the
stuff
of scholars and the fact that scholars
are now attacking
insight makes that second definition
highly relevant here so the stuff of
scholars so this is
this is a little this reminds me then of
uh a way that i used to begin
uh generally my first my first lecture
in most of my programs when i was
when i was a college professor you
remember those right where you're headed
yeah
um and i always began with the
philosophy of science
lecture because you know about about
epistemology and how it is that we make
claims of truth how it is that we know
what we claim to be
how it is that we think what is true is
true
uh and uh what i would say and actually
there's there's
there's a ton in those those lectures
that would be relevant here
um but i would ask students you know
what is it that makes someone a
scientist
and while you know no one would ever
give these examples to me
i would caricature what was in people's
head and say well of course you need a
lab coat
and you need glassware and you know you
need you need the stuff of science right
and of course neither of us ever did the
kind of science that required glassware
or lab coats no it was rubber boots and
machetes right it was rubber roots and
machetes and you know
we both preferred that kind of science
it was fun and you know as
as the science that people who use
glassware and lab coats
presumably find that engaging as well
but um
our image of what makes you a scientist
you know just
this can be useful in some ways right
like once you have an image in your head
of what makes someone a doctor
when the person who looks like a doctor
comes into the room
perhaps you have more trust that they
actually know what they're talking about
and of course that can be gamed and it
has been
uh but the fact that uh scientists
often look a certain way does not mean
that people who look that way are doing
science
the fact that doctors may often have a
stethoscope around their neck i'm not
sure they ever do anymore but
doesn't mean that a person with a
stethoscope around their neck has any
medical knowledge or insight whatsoever
ability to diagnose and the fact that a
person
uh you know uses what you say the tools
of of
scholars you know perhaps has a passing
familiarity with how one might cite a
paper that someone else has written
there's has no bearing on whether or not
that person actually has
any insight any ability to actually
understand what was in those other
papers
or in the ability uh to analyze the
current moment
yeah at some level the metaphor we're
looking for is capture
and critical race theory existed in many
departments
and those departments were always
died in the wool with this ideology
and ideology really has no place in in
academic study right but what has
happened is the capture
of the university structure itself by
these
ideological departments and that capture
results in all of the tools that
should be deployed on behalf of
science and other kinds of insight being
co-opted
and now functioning ironically to attack
those things hence what we've talked
about here before
which is the autoimmune disease aspect
of this right to have
scientific uh journals for example
science and nature broadcasting shut
down
stem is very odd because if anyone
should be
dead set against the shutting down of
stem it would be science and nature
right but
the journal the journal that's right but
the point is well they have staffs of
people and those staffs of people are
subject to the same pressures that
people are now
facing uh everywhere and it shouldn't be
surprising to hear them say
ironic things for the same reason that
you know
somebody you've known for your whole
life who you know doesn't harbor any
racism
right might be heard to say that they
are a racist um
they've seen the light right uh you know
a journal that you know at the very
least should be a champion of the idea
of science even if
it doesn't always achieve it uh can be
made to broadcast an attack on the idea
of science
um you know by virtue of social pressure
which is
so much of where we are yeah so what do
you think
uh will be the ramifications
of this memorandum if um
you know i guess i guess two possible
ways to answer that
uh one is it going to be successful uh
and i
you know obviously it should be that is
you know a memorandum
about what happens in the federal
workforce uh
from the executive office should should
be implementable
um and then if if we think that it will
be successful
i wonder what the what the rippling
effects are elsewhere
you know do other government workers for
instance at the state level
who you know i only say government
workers because i imagine that maybe
there's some overlap between the kind of
work that a state worker in some realm
might do and the kind of work that a
federal worker in the same realm might
do
do state workers start trying to jump
ship from state work and go into federal
work because they are being
effectively you know i don't know
i was gonna say witch-hunted but you
know maybe not yet some some people for
sure
but they are worried for their job
security and
for the integrity of the work that they
can do
because these trainings come with these
implicit threats
at best um whether they move from
state work to federal work on that basis
i don't know it's kind of
uh long term it's a trend you can
imagine short term it's hard to imagine
how it even works
but yes over time uh
to the extent that anything shows the
ability to resist
these trends it's going to accumulate
all of the people who understand what's
wrong
with this ideology and frankly it's
going to create
a concentration of competence and
courage
in anything that resists the
concentration of competence and courage
yep a concentration of competence and
courage
and um that has implications for this
movement that are
should be very frightening it should
stop them in their tracks
right you are going to drive out all of
the most
competent people all of the people who
actually have courage you're going to
drive them to your enemy's side
that is a losing play and so well it's a
losing play
uh in some contexts and it's potentially
a winning play
depending on what their goals are and
others so apropos
the conversation that you had had with
nancy roman which just posted a couple
days ago which i've only listened to
about half of but i was listening to
this morning um you know if their goal
as she says has been said to her by some
of
the agitators on the streets is in fact
to leave people with the sense that the
police are are
not just incompetent but dangerous and
so everyone should want want them gone
then the combination of defunding
at the same time as as many good police
or police somewhat near retirement or
police just with any other options may
be leaving because who would want to be
a police officer right now at least in
some of the
places where the violence is
concentrated like portland where we live
you're going to end up with uh with
a police force that is worse than it was
because you can't attract new people
because the resources are
are and you don't have many of the good
people you already had
because they are leaving and if the
stated goal is
to basically you know just as has been
suggested for
the united states postal service right
like if if
what what is trying to be done is to
leave people with a sense that the usps
can't do anything right and therefore it
needs to be defunded
well demonstrate how bad it is if the
if if in this case and you know it just
happens to be the other side of the
political aisle but it's the same kind
of technique it's the same strategy
like okay let's let's demonstrate how
bad the police are so that people are
fed up with them
and make it really hard to attract new
people so
in in that case leaving the courageous
and competent
or having the courageous the competent
flee is useful for the goal
well it is going to create
many of the features that those who are
marching
claim are driving them right so it is
going to create
a incompetent underfunded and therefore
brutal and arbitrary police force and
the competent people
are going to end up in a private version
of policing right where they are
not constrained by the same kinds of
forces
that constrain public policing so
basically
this is frightening enough that people
are going to end up sourcing their own
private security yeah the rich are going
to have security they're going to have
the police and they're going to have the
ability to
wield them and the public is going to be
left with warlordism
and underfunded uh
not so hot police officers protecting
them which is going to work very badly
which is going to create
a huge disadvantage for people who are
subject to public policing relative to
those who have a
private police force it's going to drive
those with the resources
to group together right it's going to
create
more gated communities it's going to
create
that's right you know it's going to
create a
cities you know if people flee
the west coast to go to austin because
it's like a little
uh piece of the west coast in texas
where the center might still hold
right it's going to create these islands
where
the old version of things is still going
to function
and it's going to leave you know
something more mad max like out in
the vast swaths of the country where
this illogic was allowed to take over
well i guess i don't it's not clear to
me that this
madness is being allowed to take over in
the broad swaths of the country you know
the places in the country with low
population density do not seem to be
particularly susceptible
to this kind of ideology now part of
that may be that
there aren't the numbers to you know to
swarm
but i think actually that this just
falls out along somewhat traditional
political lines and there are many of us
there are many of us
who have been on the left our entire
lives who object
strenuously to this thing that is going
on but
uh more people on the right are more
likely to be
sort of law and order enthusiasts who
are more likely to have stood up
in defense of you know strong police to
keep the peace
in the past yeah i agree with your uh
rural urban distinction but if you play
this through
if you look at california for example
and you look at the
the pandering that is going on by
politicos
who are attempting to wield
fiscal policy in a way that placates
the mob they are going to drive the
entire
business sector out of california
because it's going to be
impossible to be competitive if you do
so from there
so then the question is what happens to
the rural parts of california that may
not be crazy
as the urban parts of california
collapse because
the tax base has fled to some place
where law and order still functions
this is a very unstable
and dangerous trajectory that we are
rapidly heading down
well i mean to some degree presumably we
are
far afield from any place that i have
expertise or prepared for today but um
to take california which is at some
point it was like the fifth largest
economy in the world if it was a nation
state
on unto itself i think um presumably
there
and again i'm i i hope to be corrected
if i'm wrong here um
much of the wealth of california comes
from
the uh the basically the population
density
and the big corporations that are in the
big cities along the coast san diego los
angeles
um seattle that's not in california oh
i'm sorry
she said along the west coast you're
right within california along the coast
within california
you have basically a string of cities up
through you know
it peters off after the bay area you
know eureka is that big
but basically the bottom half of coastal
california
is you know i don't know to 50 miles
inland which is a tiny percentage of the
land mass of california
is presumably where most of the wealth
of california has been generated
and so to the degree i know that you
know barstow and fresno
and you know other places
um inland in california don't have the
kinds of resources for instance in their
public schools
that the coastal areas do but they have
more than they would
absent the wealth being generated on the
coast right so
um they will begin to suffer as
the big as the businesses leave because
uh the taxation is becoming punitive
uh for uh four businesses to stay in
california
and so i'm not an expert here either but
it seems to me that there's one thing
that can't leave
california easily which is big ag right
right yeah but hollywood can leave right
yeah
hollywood can leave the tech sector can
leave
lots of these things the tech sector
kind of is and you know silicon valley
is a thing and
um but i remember what they're called
you know i i was talking with you the
other day about like what
why couldn't portland become silicon
forest like why why couldn't we attract
that well we can't right now because
they're a bunch of
small number of loons being allowed to
run rampant on the streets
um but you know austin there are a few
other places with silicon something
um in in the country who that are
becoming concentrated areas
uh you know new york has always been an
area of
uh you know for theater for
entertainment but not film and
television
so you know vancouver and not in
washington but in canada
um you know to some degree can hollywood
move there
um if it was trying to leave the country
entirely i don't you know i
i don't i don't know how that works well
so it can move anywhere
what it wants to do so because lifestyle
is such a big part of what hollywood
and the um the tech sector is actually
about right the question is where can
the people who inhabit it move that fits
their sense of how they want to live
that also allows the thing to function
and um you know
vancouver seems plausible a little cold
but um
a little pricey not for hollywood oh no
vancouver
at least for a while was literally the
most expensive place to live in the
world
sure and you know san francisco too but
my point is these industries that profit
from
the vastness of the audience for what
they are delivering
can afford those prices those prices
are not prohibitive if you are in this
sort of
unlimited upside industry
well maybe right so
in terms of sort of the growth of
hollywood in the early mid 20th century
um la is i mean la's a fascinating city
that has changed with every decade
and one of the things that happened i
think is that
people with not a dime to their name
could actually come
and say you know i'm gonna i'm gonna go
and try to make it
uh in hollywood and if
in modern times people who are trying to
make it
have to go to a city where rent is so
prohibitive that you simply can't you
you you can't take a job as a waiter
or uh doing white-collar work or
something and actually even pay rent
while you try to break into the system
that cuts the creative input of you know
young people and aspiring you know
actors directors writers
choreographers cinematographers
everything um off at the knees
only sort of you know the the fact is
it's a cost of doing business thing
so to the extent that silicon valley
needed to bust people in to do the
the grunt work you know they figured it
out
um and hollywood will do the same yeah i
don't actually i don't think so
i think silicon bussing people you know
google buses through san francisco
uh for you know grunt work tech workers
is different than
people trying to make it break into
entertainment i don't know but you
you're imagining that hollywood needs to
function
in the the good tiny fraction of it that
functions that allows people who are
creative to land there and do amazing
stuff
right but that's you know that's the
tiniest sliver
on the surface of the thing that's not
the core of the business
so the core of the business can be made
to function and to turn out its garbage
um anywhere and you know to the extent
that
there's a basically a tax that needs to
be paid in order to
to um to staff the part of it that
won't be able to afford the big houses
it'll they'll figure it out
okay but i i mean allow me to have the
hope
that these businesses actually still
have that sliver which is what should be
a vast majority of what they're doing
which is
allow for the creation of things
heretofore on the thought
heretofore unimagined uh where people
come together
and share ideas that have never been
shared before and create things that
have never been created before
this is what tech is supposed to be
doing and hollywood is supposed to be
doing and science is supposed to be
discovering rather than creating for the
most part
engineering is supposed to be uh
creating and discovering and
you know if if we are imagining the
world which doesn't allow for those
things then then every single one of
those industries is dead already
well because i i love you and because i
share your dream i won't mock you for it
so
um sorry but i mean i you know i
yes i agree i would like to live in that
world too but um wow are we not headed
that direction
but let's go back to this other point in
passing the the silicon forest
point because i really think it's it's
essential please um
so yeah here's the irony of this whole
situation
is you've got a bunch of things looking
for somewhere to go
because their uh home base is being
wrecked by lunacy
any one of these places i mean here's
the thing portland
is really screwed up at the moment but
the bones of the place are freaking
fantastic we didn't move here because we
wanted to be
surrounded by uh crazed liberals we
moved here no
i will remind you i forgot why we
thought about moving
everywhere because suddenly our uh
income was not based on any particular
location so we knew we had to move out
of olympia
and we were looking for some place to go
and it could have been anywhere that had
access to an airport
and good schools and good schools and
bandwidth i guess but uh
bandwidth yeah so that you know internet
stuff oh just a good function like
actual literal band
but that was a lot of places and we
literally considered
you know ten different towns yeah like
i've said the people at zillow if they
were paying any attention to my saved
homes would have thought we were insane
yeah they would have thought we were
nuts everything from santa fe washington
d.c
yep uh yeah all sorts of places but
anyway the point um the point here
is lots of people are looking for
somewhere to go
lots of industries are looking for
somewhere to go if california goes crazy
that's a tremendous opportunity
for anybody who can get their freaking
act together to be attractive to the
things that are fleeing california
anyone being any city
any municipality any state something
right in the case of portland portland
has
really everything you could want it's
the air is clean the quality of life is
high
at the moment it's not a cheap place to
live but compared to the big
compared to almost every place else uh
that
uh that are considered to be places
you know that the people who are fleeing
california that we're talking to are
moving to
yeah portland is still less expensive
than
the vast majority of coastal and even
inland cities like
austin and santa fe and denver and such
there are endless opportunities for you
know
within an hour's drive or two hours
drive the number of
fun cool things to do in the mountains
on the rivers and all is
is is great so you know quality of life
is high
here's the question all you got to do
in order to attract all of the stuff
that is fleeing
these major economic hubs is figure out
how to resist the thing that is causing
people to flee if you could compellingly
make the argument if not just
portland but oregon could make the
argument hey guess what
we are going to resist this woke madness
right and what we are going to do
is we are going to do things that are
hospitable to the kinds of people
who are economic drivers
we're going to give them an iron-clad
assurance that they will be protected to
do what they do
here the effect of this would be such a
massive burst of
growth for the state of oregon that it
would be able to
elevate everybody's state of well-being
to the extent that you wanted to create
a model state that actually addressed
the
unfairness right you would have
tremendous resources with which to do it
in other words you could have
glorious public schools right at a
relatively inexpensive
price point so you could still make the
place very hospitable and because it has
many of the features of quality of life
that drove people to california in the
first place
it would be a natural place to go but we
won't be able to do it
because our politicos are so dim that
they can't understand
that there's an argument they could make
hey everybody of
every color we can make your life much
better without actually figuring out how
to produce anything new
just by being hospitable to people who
are already producing this stuff
right portland could be the next big
place
yeah no it absolutely could and i think
um one thing but then i think this may
be the place to show the video that you
uh were showing me with governor brown
um answering to governor kate brown of
of oregon
answering in a press conference to the
question of
why in the letter that she just
published she talks about
uh the risk to people of oregon from
white supremacists and doesn't make any
mention of the people
who are actually engaging in the vast
majority of violence on the streets of
portland
uh which is far left antifa black bloc
you know choose your choose your
description um yeah okay let's let's go
so
let's see the video
yes thank you so much good morning
governor we've had some viewers ask
why your anti-violence statement this
week about ongoing unrest in portland
mentioned white supremacy but did not
also include mention of groups like
antifa and other bad actors
what was that and also what is your
response to city commissioners chloe
daley and joanne hardesty not signing on
to that anti-violence statement
um so the first question is why did i
specifically hold out white supremacist
organizations
because my goal my vision for a future
oregon is to build a better oregon where
everyone can thrive
and that means eradicating racism
and so my understanding of these
organizations is they're based on hate
and i think it makes it really difficult
for us to build
what dr king would call a beloved
community
all right so
what we discover here is that the
instinct
to pander to these constituencies is so
great
that governor brown and ted wheeler are
going to bypass
portland ted wheeler yep did i did i say
it wrong no you just didn't specify who
it was yeah
mayor wheeler and governor brown are
going to bypass the opportunity
to turn oregon and
portland into a shining example of what
is
possible to make it a absolutely
hospitable
place in which its liberal values are
allowed
to shine by virtue of having the
resources to actually
solve some problems it's particularly
notable
in oregon to my mind because unlike the
other two lower 48 west coast states
california to a large degree and
washington to a lesser degree than
california
don't just have one major metropolitan
area right they they have multiple
multiple concentrations um with you know
multiple
mayors making different decisions etc
oregon's only got one like you know
eugene and corvallis are both
are both campus towns college towns and
you know bend is growing but
really this stuff is concentrated in
portland and
uh my my sense and
i mean i i've actually even even just
going a half an hour out of portland
uh we we see a different
kind of of oregon people here
in portland are not pleased with what's
going on they are not
and some of them are buying the rhetoric
that is being trotted out but they don't
think that any of this is making sense
outside of portland my sense is
people don't buy the rhetoric they just
they look at this and they say what the
hell is going on
and no way no how is the rest of oregon
going to go along
with what is being allowed to pass for
i don't even know what it's been allowed
past for you know democracy some
somehow in the streets in portland yeah
most of most of the people of oregon
um who don't live in portland uh
see this actually i think with with
greater clarity
than people who are here in portland oh
no doubt
people who are here in portland are
parroting the rhetoric at the very least
at such a high rate that they can't
figure out
that a great many of the people probably
a majority of the people in portland
are frightened of this and want somebody
to save them from it they're just not
saying so and so we have the tragedy of
our
mayor and governor catering to the
rhetoric
rather than catering to what people
actually want
um yeah and you know i mean i think to
go back to this this memorandum
that came out of um out of the executive
branch yesterday this does
exactly go back to critical race theory
this the stuff that's going on in the
streets
is the same thing as what is going on in
our schools and
our the the corporate trainings and all
i mean i had
i had a woman that i know kind of
who lives in portland this week
assure me that there were had been
outbreaks of racism at a local high
school
in the last couple of years and when i
pressed her
she couldn't come up with any examples
and she admitted well i hadn't been
paying that close attention
and you know but certainly there's been
an upswing in racism
and you know i i pressed her enough um
that she was a little bit surprised
to be asked and clearly thought that me
pressing her
was evidence that i don't believe in
racism at all
and in fact actually am probably a
racist myself
like this this is how the rhetoric is is
spreading
the same people who can go downtown and
frankly
there are you know there are some
so-called reporters who are coming to
portland and saying hey i'm in a park
and i'm eating my breakfast burrito and
there's no problem
i wasn't attacked by antifa well to hell
with you people like
go downtown at any moment of the day and
tell me that looks like a functioning
city it
doesn't it's not a functioning city
everyone who actually lives here
and has gone downtown at any moment in
the last three months knows that
and if you go downtown after night after
after after nightfall or go to one of
the many city parks
where the conflagrations are beginning
and then into one of the many areas that
these
that these that these hoodlums are being
allowed to to take over
you cannot come away with the sense that
this is a functioning city
it's not so um i've had the experience
in multiple places i've had it in
portland where you know i try to be
i'm careful how i say things but i try
uh
never to leave a misimpression about
what i actually think is going on so
when people say this you know
this rhetoric about uh anti-racism and
stuff
i find a way to point out that um i
don't believe that this is anti-racism
and that i'm frightened of what it's
doing people confess to me
all the time right like in these
interpersonal
interactions and you know they confess
oh
i am also frightened of this blah blah
blah blah so there's a lot of stuff
going on right below the surface
just below and you know i'm also hearing
it
not locally here i'm hearing lots of
people
who we know and i will never cough them
up i'm not going to say who but
um people are frequently telling me you
know i'm
contemplating political stuff i never
would have thought before because
you know this is really scary and so
anyway because look at what's coming out
of the executive branch
right right this the stuff that's coming
out of the executive branch from a guy
who these people you're talking about
don't have any respect for yeah now he's
doing things
that are necessary and respectable well
if you
just use the following generating
function you and i have both said
versions
of trump is a political genius right
you've called him a savant yeah okay
he's a political genius
i don't think he's ideological no right
in no way
the idea that he's going to bring
fascism down like no he's a narcissist
well actually
he might bring fascism down if it was a
popular thing to do but i don't think
it's
not because he's into fascism right and
the fact is if
if you know if some kind of uh
reasonable or at least functional
leftism was the thing he might be
showing up on that side
he's self-interested and he's riding
these waves so here's the point
you've got a huge number of people
anybody who's got any reason left to
them at all
is knows that something has to halt the
march of critical race theory and all of
its outgrowths right we cannot have
people confronting each other
in a cafe and have nothing uh happen
right you cannot have people targeting
uh
members of some mainstream political
movement in the middle of the street and
shooting them
right so somebody has to do something
and trump is detecting hey there's a
vast constituency out there that wants
something done and isn't feeling like
they can say so
yeah so now he's tapping into it of
course right
so you should expect to do it and here's
the thing
uh let's put unity aside for a second i
do believe unity is
vastly more possible than people give it
credit for and
the longer the democratic party refuses
to acknowledge what's
going on and adds fuel to the fire the
greater the chances of something unusual
like unity working
become but if we take unity out of the
picture for a second
um i think trump is going to win
uh handily and this is before we even
get to the debates and there's a
question
yeah the democrats have given us
effectively
a scarecrow in place of a candidate
right
they've given us something that looks
takes human form but is not really
capable of delivering
on that wasn't very nice it's not very
nice on the other hand
why are people angry at me for saying
such things shouldn't they be angry
at the democratic party for delivering
this absolutely yes
so i don't know how they get the
scarecrow through the debate maybe
no you know maybe they've got a plan but
um
i don't think it's going to work so and
we're not prepared for this but didn't
you tell me
that pelosi said something to the effect
of well biden shouldn't legitimize
trump by agreeing to debate him like
shouldn't legitimize the sitting
president by agreeing to debate him is
that not an
out for someone who can't debate or you
know if if it's not i've never heard one
it was beautiful you can imagine the
dumb shits in the democratic party who
are responsible for political strategy
getting together and saying all right
here's what we're going to do nancy
you're going to tell you're going to
tell biden that he shouldn't debate so
as not to legitimize trump because
nobody wants trump legitimized
right and then biden will be able to say
oh no i'm debating him so that'll make
him look strong
oh this is great you could just imagine
them setting that plan
up right and you know it went off with a
whimper and everybody saw through it
right so anyway okay
at what point are you going to
acknowledge
that we have handed the responsibility
for recapturing the white house to a
bunch of people
whose understanding of this whole
process is that of a third grader
right and they've blown it quite
predictably and the clock is ticking and
nobody's got a plan b
like at some point with the ring
they're totally waiting for their snack
yeah
yeah political geniuses in the
democratic dnc a bunch of juice boxes
and send them on their way
totally oh i love it i love it um
yeah why didn't we think of that juice
box we probably could have settled this
if we you know
all right where are we um so we are uh
how how far
are we in zach
okay um so um what where where would you
like to go we wanted to
uh there are a couple so on this my
prediction
and by the way i've gotten one
prediction very wrong here and nobody's
taken me to task for it which i think
means they must be
somebody's holding it in reserve what is
it i predicted that biden wasn't going
to get the nomination
i was wrong about that okay um no big
deal i've been writing about a lot of
stuff but okay
yeah that one was uh that they were
going to be they were going to pull it
somehow last minute
yeah which you know after i predicted it
i thought no that's not right i think
it's still likely but it'd be after the
nomination because then that gives the
dnc the ability to
swap rather than if you do it before the
convention then
technically the delegates have the
opportunity to do something else which
doesn't sound like the dnc so probably i
shouldn't have
made that prediction i still think the
model is right i still think they
know that he's a placeholder for either
party rule or
you know kamala harris is party rule
incarnate or whatever their
plan is but um but anyway i got it wrong
but anyway i'm predicting here trump is
going to win by a large margin
the reason is obvious because the fact
of people not being able to say what
they think
causes noise in the polling that you
can't
overcome right people people will hold
their nose
like many of them did in 2016 and say i
don't like the guy personally
and i don't trust him over in this space
you know over in leadership space
but but he's actually willing to do some
of the things that need to be done
and the democrats don't seem willing to
do so right except that
by setting this in motion they're now
setting us up for
the question we still can't answer right
turned out the guy wasn't hitler
he was hitler we'd know it by now right
but okay not an ideologue
what happens when you elect the guy for
his second term
and he doesn't face another election now
i don't think
anything hitlerian is the answer here
but the point is
we're gonna find out if this if i'm
right about what's gonna happen
and unity 2020 does not manage to pull
it out which i still
believe is a possibility and we can talk
more about that but if trump
uh is um sworn in again
uh then we're gonna find out what
trump with the gloves off looks like
right and that uh
i think is a failure mode
waiting to happen that this is a
disaster that is going to feed
the crazed left many of the things that
it's going to need to fashion some story
that's going to justify it's becoming
even more unhinged
and anyway as as his election in 2016
did
yeah frankly right i mean the
polarization
uh was already well underway before
trump appeared on the scene whenever he
first
began to run but um certainly the
both the election and then the
inauguration uh were
step functions in the uh in the
depravity
of the techniques used by the
would-be activists on the left yeah now
we can hope
that something else would unfold we can
hope that
um in light of not having to face
another election that
trump might begin to think about um
legacy yeah about confounding
his critics by
doing unifying things and in fact going
up against critical race theory
is such a thing i don't really expect
this because for one thing
those who do the writing of history have
announced that effectively there's
nothing that he could do that they would
record as positive
so at some level they are
disincentivizing his behaving in our
collective interest
yep so it's a disaster a disaster
waiting to happen of course
um can we show the video of the uh
the new york city uh
rioters
[Applause]
where rioters are disrupting
uh i believe patrons of
a restaurant frightening them breaking
things
driving them out chastising them
publicly
and that was in new york yep that's in
rochester and then can we see the
march in new york
[Music]
[Applause]
so here you have people
[Music]
[Applause]
is that the chant about burning all the
precincts down yes every city every town
just to the ground and then there was a
death to america a
banner in there so this is sort of
announcing uh
what their plans are now i've heard
people say that this is
being funded by those who want trump to
win
uh certainly possible um on the other
hand you don't need that
because the numskulls who uh hold this
anarchist ideology are perfectly capable
of saying insane things like this
in advance of an election either as an
accelerationist
move or just out of pure stupidity but
um
the point is they are setting us up for
a trump win
one way or the other one way or the
other and uh
i think we should increasingly expect it
and i think those who think
that that's the end of the world should
start thinking outside the box because
you know what
your party [ __ ] up your party
delivered you an answer that you can't
beat them
yeah no that's that is unfortunately
right
um let's let's
riff on this from 1984 for a couple
minutes wonderful shall we
uh page
three okay everybody turn your hymnals
to page three uh
i don't know why books are paginated
this way it says page five but it starts
on page three so
early in 1984 the famous
and important book by george orwell
written in
1949 originally i think yep um
we have the ministry of truth
mini true in newspeak was startingly
different from any other object in sight
it was an enormous pyramidal structure
of glittering white concrete soaring up
terrace after terrace
300 meters into the air from where
winston stood it was just possible to
read picked out on its white face in
elegant lettering the three slogans of
the party
war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength
those are the three slogans of the party
um that we hear about in the rest of
this
uh unfortunately prussian book war is
peace
freedom is slaver ignorance is strength
so my claim
is that we have achieved two of these
three
that we um are now regularly hearing
that war is peace not in those terms
but the term mostly peaceful as we have
covered here before
basically means that anything you know
any one who wishes to portray violence
as
peaceful simply has to emphasize um
the percentage of time or the percentage
of locales or whatever metric you want
to use
to game the statistic means that it is
peaceful so
if you could show um you want to show
that headline i sent you and then
uh show us the document on which it's
based so here the guardian and you can
find this in
many different publications nearly all
black lives matter protests
are peaceful despite trump narrative
report fines so it is trump that is
portraying these things as violent
um and so um you
i have a couple of screenshots from that
doctor yeah please show them okay
uh so here an overwhelmingly peaceful
movement actually turn this off for a
second zach
um before we go there this this document
uh let me see if i can find it um is
sorry um
just published um it's called
from september 2020 okay you can show
this now zach for just a moment
um this is demonstrations some political
violence in america new data for summer
2020
and it presumes to be
a very measured and careful sort of data
forward data centered type analysis
turn turn off my screen framework sac
and let me just show a couple of
screenshots from
uh from this here we go an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement it
concludes
the vast majority of demonstration
events associated with the blm movement
are non-violent i'll show you the map in
a minute
in more than 93 of all demonstrations
connected to the movement demonstrators
have not engaged in violence or
destructive activity
peaceful protests are reported in over 2
400 distinct locations around the
country
violent demonstrations meanwhile have
been limited to fewer than 220 locations
under 10 of the areas that experience
peaceful protests
in many urban areas like portland oregon
for example which has seen sustained
unrest since floyd's killing
violent demonstrations are largely
confined to specific blocks
rather than dispersed throughout the
city here they reference the
um unassailable source that is cnn
as if that is is going to be trustworthy
here and here is
one of the maps
of of of their conclusions
uh this is an organization that says
that they share all their data but
interestingly
um none of these data are appear to be
findable on their site at the moment so
it's really
hard for me to figure out how it is that
they have assessed
how many demonstrations there have been
for instance or whether or not the
demonstration type has been a protest or
a riot
in portland for instance there have been
i can't remember the numbers but
you know some some number of nights the
the nightly thing that goes from
relatively peaceful to
really really not which has been like
clockwork every night
some number of those by no means a
majority and certainly not all have been
declared riots by the police
but to a observer thinking does that
look like a riot to me
pretty much every night there's been
something somewhere in portland that
looked like a riot
how many of those were actually called
riots now we have on this map you know
big orange circle
that is orange over portland which
suggests that there were yes indeed a
lot of riots
um but without access to the data we
have no way of assessing how it is that
they concluded
these numbers oh and i suspect that
their
use that they do not invoke the term
riot based on the behavior that they
invoke it based on whether a riot has
been declared and i can tell you one of
the things i learned watching the
protests here
in portland was that there are all kinds
of things that are clearly a riot that
the police do not declare a riot for
some reason that has to do with the way
they're policing them
but lots of violence goes on outside of
the category right
i would also if you can go back to that
um map the map okay here we go
yeah you can also see that even the idea
of peaceful protests is a phony story
because mostly what went on was the
growing of gmo corn
right that's not a protest that doesn't
even involve people
right so they're selling this well but
they're very focused on the idea that
protests were a big story but protests
are a result of the news bias in favor
of protests
you haven't seen the growing of corn
reported on the news but on a percentage
basis you can see based on this map a
large amount of that territory
is dedicated to the growing of crops
which you almost never hear about so
i honestly have no idea what you're
talking about i'm using their rubric
right where they're going to declare
stuff peaceful because
you know they haven't gotten around to
the rioting yeah for example
and my point is the idea that we focus
on
you know you and i will focus on the
fact that as i think every night but
one for the last 90 some
has involved violence in portland that
would suggest a large percentage of what
goes on in portland is like the run-up
to violence or violence itself
right but the idea that it was mostly
peaceful because there were many hours
in which there was no violence
and there you know the city is
overwhelmingly not involved in any
protests whatsoever
a lot of peaceable eating of breakfast
burritos right my point is an intuitive
rubric here where the point is
huh there's been violence every night in
portland for the last 90.
that sounds kind of unusually violent
right
rather than oh it was mostly peaceful by
what rubric
and my point is if we're going to do
everything by this mind-numbing
you know statistical analysis that
pretends to be quantitative on the basis
that most of what it was was not violent
you know as i pointed out on a previous
live stream
um the uh the motorcade in dallas in
1963 was overwhelmingly peaceful
i mean you know why anybody even reports
on the violence is hard to understand
clearly bias in reporting right and my
point is um
you know the same analysis suggested
what's being ignored is the growing of
corn
um in favor of news that focus on
protests
because there's a lot more growing of
corn than there is protesting
you think it's the corn lobby that's
behind us oh geez i fear my point has
been lost but
um but yes uh so anyway back to the
point yeah the point is
war is peace um this is a statistical
version of that
right mostly peaceful is
uh a way to ignore the violence
right now um ignorance is
remind me freedom is slavery is the
second one and ignorance is strength yes
ignorance is strength we have also
achieved this one
right shut down stem the enlightenment
is a white
thing logic is is a tool of
white oppression math is a tool of white
supremacy math is a tool of white
supremacy
all of these things are an attack on
reason right and so they are an embrace
of ignorance
obviously for what purpose for the
purpose of wielding power
so here we've got two of the slogans on
that pyramid
and we've fully achieved them now
freedom is slavery i don't think we're
quite there yet but we're headed there
right we're definitely headed there
because um what we have
are people putting other people through
struggle sessions on the basis that what
comes out of this
will be the liberation that we all seek
right through the admission of things
that aren't true so
i don't think we have quite as clean an
example on that one but at some level
we know that we are engaged in the
process that orwell was responding to
because the match between the things we
are now
contemplating and the slogans on the
pyramid which seem beyond
you know ridiculous the match is just
too damn close
yeah it is yeah it is yup
one hour all right well um let's see
we should probably talk very briefly
about uh
unity and then maybe we take our
our intermission and answer your super
chat questions when we come back
yeah so let me just say unity
had its twitter account suspended as
most of you will know the twitter
account remains suspended the
information we have on why it was
suspended
to the extent we have any information at
all does not in
any way match the results of our
exhaustive internal investigation
right we did an internal investigation
to make sure that there wasn't something
we didn't know about that match the
accusations that were being leveled
against us
we found nothing like what twitter has
told us and they haven't told us much
so i am not sure what is going on but i
do have the sense that we are being
politically targeted
because obviously anybody
that um speaks as openly as we do about
the corruption of the duopoly
the necessity of us doing something
about it
the fact that we face an existential
threat from continuing to follow the
duopoly
it's an all hands on deck moment that
thing
is a threat to the woke movement which
clearly
exists inside twitter and is wielding
rules arbitrarily
in its favor it's a threat to
twitter's disproportionate access that
it gains
through the manipulation of the
political process so in other words to
the extent
that unity is a challenge to corruption
very powerful
economic entities like twitter uh may be
hostile to it now how this all unfolds
we don't know
i will say um personally
i don't suspect that jack himself
is aware that what he is is saying about
why we were suspended is nonsense and
transparently so
i actually suspect he is being fed bad
information
um i don't know that to be true maybe
that's me hoping that it's true because
i want jack to be a good guy but
jack if you're listening you should
really look into what you are being told
about
unity 2020 and you should check for
yourself whether it adds up
you we were able to check this very
thoroughly you have better data than we
do because you have the records of
who contacted twitter and did what
you've got i p addresses presumably
you should be able to tell that the
things that you are saying to us about
what we have done are incorrect
and um to the extent that your
organization is willing to meddle in a
natural process
of democracy in which citizens attempt
to escape the duopoly paradigm which is
our right
that you would interfere that with that
is very very troubling and
it needs to be reversed immediately
all right we have arrived at the end of
this first section
of this live stream we have um
we have announcements uh sure just the
usual usual announcements
uh last sunday we had our monthly
private q a
uh and it was it was good you can access
all the past ones and get access to the
live
one for next month at my patreon um get
access to
the discord server um on either of our
patreons and this morning
you had uh your two hour conversation
with
patreons at the 100 level and tomorrow
morning you will have one
for patrons at the 250 level yep this
morning's conversation was
off the hook i'm hoping tomorrow's
conversation will be off the hook but
you know
it's too early to judge but i would
think so yes
all right so we will be answering your
super chat questions from this hour
and the ones that you pose next hour
when we come back in about 15 minutes
all right in the meantime be well